let me make a final point for a while
now the main contribution of some of my
friends on the other side of the aisle
have made in the fight against ISIL is
to criticize this administration and me
for not using the phrase radical Islam
that's the key they tell us we can't
beat I cyl unless we call them radical
Islamists what exactly would using this
label accomplish what exactly would it
change would it make ISIL less committed
to trying to kill Americans would it
bring in more allies is there a military
strategy that is served by this the
answer is none of the above calling a
threat by a different name does not make
it go away this is a political
distraction since before I was president
I've been clear about how extremist
groups have perverted Islam to justify
terrorism as president I have repeatedly
called on our Muslim friends and allies
at home and around the world to work
with us to reject this twisted
interpretation of one of the world's
great religions there's not been a
moment in my seven and a half years as
president where we have not been able to
pursue a strategy because we didn't use
the label radical Islam
not once has an advisor mind said man if
we really use that phrase we're going to
turn this whole thing around not once so
someone seriously thinks that we don't
know who we're fighting if there's
anyone out there who thinks were
confused about who our enemies are that
would come as a surprise to the
thousands of terrorists who we've taken
off the battlefield if the implication
is that those of us up here and the
thousands of people around the country
and around the world who are working to
defeat ISIL aren't taking the fight
seriously that come as a surprise to
those who spent these last seven and a
half years dismantling al-qaeda in the
FATA for example including the men and
women in uniform who put their lives at
risk and the special forces that I
ordered to get bin Laden and are now on
the ground in Iraq and in Syria they
know full well who the enemy is so do
the intelligence and law enforcement
officers who spent countless hours
disrupting plots and protecting all
Americans including politicians who
tweet and appear on cable news shows
they know who the nature of the enemy is
so there's no magic to the phrase
radical Islam it's a political talking
point it's not a strategy and the reason
I am careful about how I describe this
threat has nothing to do with political
correctness and everything to do with
actually defeating extremism groups like
ISIL and
Qaeda want to make this war a war
between Islam and America or between
Islam and the West they want to claim
that they are the true leaders of over a
billion Muslims around the world who
reject their crazy notions they want us
to validate them by implying that they
speak for those billion plus people that
they speak for Islam that's their
propaganda that's how they recruit and
if we fall into the trap of painting all
Muslims with a broad brush and imply
that we are at war with an entire
religion then we are doing the terrorist
work for them up until this point this
argument about labels has mostly just
been partisan rhetoric and sadly we've
all become accustomed to that kind of
partisanship even when it involves the
fight against these extremist groups and
that kind of yappin has not prevented
folks across government from doing their
jobs from sacrifice and working really
hard to protect the American people but
we are now seeing how dangerous this
kind of mindset and this kind of
thinking can be we're starting to see
where this kind of rhetoric and loose
talk and sloppiness about who exactly
we're fighting where this can lead us we
now have proposals from the presumptive
Republican nominee for president of the
United States
to bar all Muslims from emigrating to
America be here language that singles
out immigrants and suggests entire
religious communities are complicit in
violence where does this stop the
Orlando killer one of the San Bernardino
killers the Fort Hood killer they were
all US citizens are we going to start
treating all Muslim Americans
differently are we going to start
subjecting them to special surveillance
we're going to start discriminating
against them because of their faith
we've heard these suggestions during the
course of this campaign do Republican
officials actually agree with this
because that's not the America we want
it doesn't reflect our democratic ideals
it won't make us more safe it will make
us less safe fuelling isil's notion that
the West hates Muslims making young
Muslims in this country and around the
world feel like no matter what they do
they're going to be under suspicion and
under attack it makes Muslim Americans
feel like their government is betraying
them it betrays the very values America
stands for we've gone through moments in
our history before when we acted out of
fear and we came to regret it
we've seen our government miss treat our
fellow citizens and it has been a
shameful part of our history this is a
country founded on basic freedoms
including freedom of religion we don't
have religious tests here our founders
our Constitution our bill of rights are
clear about that and if we ever abandon
those values we would not only make it a
lot easier to radicalize people here and
around the world but we would have
betrayed the very things we are trying
to protect the pluralism and the
openness our rule of law our civil
liberties the very things that make this
country great the very things that make
us exceptional and then the terrorists
would have won and we cannot let that
happen I will not let that happen you
know two weeks ago as that the
commencement ceremony at the Air Force
Academy and it could not have been more
inspiring to see these young people
stepping up dedicated to serve and
protect this country and part of what
was inspiring was the incredible
diversity of these cadets
we saw cadets who are straight
applauding classmates who were openly
gay we saw cadets born here in America
applauding classmates who are immigrants
and love this country so much they
decided they wanted to be part of our
armed forces we saw cadets and families
of all religions applaud cadets who are
proud patriotic Muslim Americans serving
their country in uniform ready to lay
their lives on the line to protect you
and to protect me we saw male cadets
applauding for female classmates who can
now serve in combat positions that's the
American military that's America one
team one nation those are the values
that isil's trying to destroy and we
shouldn't help them do it our diversity
in our respect for one another are
drawing up on the talents of everybody
in this country are making sure that we
are treating everybody fairly that we're
not judging people on the basis of what
faith they are or what race they are or
what ethnicity they are or what their
sexual orientation is
that's what makes this country great
that's a spirit we see in Orlando that's
the unity and resolve that will allow us
to defeat ISIL that's what will preserve
our values and our ideals that define us
as Americans that's how we're going to
defend this nation and that's how we're
going to defend our way of life thank
you very much